let's read this first story you may have
seen the viral clip senator rand paul
i'm sorry dr senator rand paul
urges people to defy covet mandates they
can't arrest all of us that's a bold
statement he says quote
it's time for us to resist
they can't arrest all of us they can't
keep all of your kids home from school
we don't have to accept the mandates
lockdowns and harmful policies of the
petty tyrants and bureaucrats we can
simply say no not again paul also
threatened to hold up every bill with
two amendments if any school system
tries to keep kids out of the classroom
this fall one to defund them and another
to allow parents the choice of where
their money goes for their child's
education
that should be law anyway we should have
school choice but he says uh there's a
quote
children are falling behind in school
and are being harmed physically and
physiol and psychologically by the
tactics that you have used to keep them
from the classroom during the last year
we won't allow it again
now of course there's already a bunch of
people who are uh claiming that he's
telling people to outright defy the cdc
in general which was the funniest thing
i saw from that they were like rand paul
says to uh to defy the cdc and i'm like
he specifically said the restrictions
that he called anti-science i don't
think he said the entirety of the cdc
and that distinction is kind of
important because the cdc does more than
just talk about coven mind you they talk
about a lot of things but um
man what should people do i don't know
you live in uh the the authoritarian
hellscape what do you think i do live in
the authoritarian hellscape and i gotta
be honest with you i thought we had a
shot you know i thought things were not
going to quite get this bad um a lot of
people in new york city are vaccinated i
think we have some rather high
percentage of new yorkers who are
vaccinated there are people who still
don't want to get vaccinated
it's not because they haven't had access
to it so at this point they are making
their grown-up choice
to
undergo medical treatment or not
for some reason
this is not good enough for
the leftist government
de blasio has always been a disaster
he's been a disaster since the moment he
was elected he is not an intelligent man
he is not a good elected leader
uh he has absolutely no principles
whatsoever there's nothing worthwhile
about him at all
uh but i did not think that he would
literally throw the entire city under
the bus just in order to uh you know
satisfy this this weird idea that he has
so where everybody needs to just do what
he says so yeah so there's this idea
this vaccine passport
cuomo created an excel they actually
call it the excelsior pass you can
download it on your phone it will track
your coveted test results it will track
your covet vaccine you can show it uh
and additionally part of the idea with
the excelsior pass is that if you show
it to get into a sporting event or what
have you
you also have to show supposedly your id
this is what it says on the new york
state website so that they can prove
that it's actually your past so now in
order to
move about freely in the city where you
live you have to show your papers at
various places
yeah that's what it says on the website
i don't know i haven't used it i won't
obviously i'm never going to download
something so the government can track me
on my phone i mean we're probably
already tracked whatever but i'm not
going to voluntarily do that
this this is interesting because it's
it enters the public sphere as like oh
but it's about vet you got your vaccine
already what's the big deal and you need
your id and then you need your id and
then
what's next that's racist right what's
next it's also racist of course well
it's racist for two reasons asking for
id is racist right democrat said so
voting and it is true in new york and
especially many of the places the black
community is the least least likely to
be vaccinated among racial demographics
yeah so that was something i was
thinking about too because you know de
blasio's paid lip service to the black
community for a long time um
even last year when we had all the blm
protests and then you had the i forget
what they were called but they were like
the covet tracker people right they're
like test and trace yeah so new york had
this like whole test and trace core and
if you tested positive for kovid um i
don't know if they still do but they
would call you
um oh yeah and track you down and de
blasio and cuomo one of the things that
they agreed on during the pandemic was
that you are not allowed to ask someone
if they have been to a protest when you
are doing a like track and trace thing
for covid
everything's a protest from now on so
you're allowed to protest without having
and and so then they said like you know
then all these reports came out that
said blm protests weren't super super
spreader events you literally weren't
allowed to ask people if they'd been to
a protest yeah once they were tracked
with covid you weren't allowed to ask
them so there's actually no way of
knowing whether or not they were super
spread out or events or not i have a
question for you what percentage of
residents of new york city do you think
are vaccinated
i think it's something like 60
it is 55.6 there you go so close yeah
it's it's that's that's half it's
absolutely
plenty of an amount i think i think
we're going to see more exodus from new
york city i think so too um there were
already like 400 000 really rich
families that left during the pandemic
the new york city school system started
out
in 2020 with 1.1 million
public school students a nice
healthy number robust school system
and i think we're down
we're in like the 800 thousands area now
whoa
is this the u.s just being crushed like
on purpose
being what crushed is the u.s being
crushed on purpose yeah
like
by some other authoritative situation
well maybe maybe not necessarily on
purpose might go too far but the
policies being put in place are just
destroying the country
yeah i think they are destroying the
country i think we have a real ethos
problem we've heard joe biden say over
and over again
that his job is to keep americans safe
the president's job is not to keep
americans safe the president's job is to
you know run the country the way that
his constituents say
and commander-in-chief of the armed
forces to technically do that and like
you know keep the country safe perhaps
but not individuals and it's not his job
to do anything other than to protect our
rights and
that's not what's going on our rights
are not being protected when we're being
treated as though we can't make
decisions about our own medical care
yeah it feels like everything but being
put into place and i
probably said this 50 million times by
now is just literally destroying the
economy and you have to ask i i
what is if if we're doing the same thing
we did last time and it didn't work last
time why are we doing the same thing
again
like they're putting in policies that
according to nbc news are going to hurt
the job the job recitation right growth
and they're putting in they're putting
into place policies that will basically
just drive people out of new york and we
did hear bill de blasio say he wanted to
convert the abandoned buildings into
public housing right so maybe in insofar
as it goes with like de blasio
on purpose isn't that far i think he
does want to completely destroy the city
i don't think he has any vision at all
or any understanding of what it is that
new york is really about the other issue
too is a matter of enforcement so
we've seen i think we were looking at
videos earlier um
in france you see police going around to
the restaurants being like oh let me see
your
let me see your documentation that
permits you to be outside of your home
uh make sure you've what are you going
to do in new york is they're going are
they going yes are the police going to
be asked to do this yeah because here's
another [ __ ] here's an issue with that
here's an issue with that first of all
if the police aren't asked to do it now
you're asking just your basic guy at the
bodega
to start demanding things of patrons
i don't know about you guys i get really
testy when people ask me for stuff that
they're not entitled to about my person
right i was telling you guys earlier
about an incident in philadelphia we
don't need to get into but
um but
if it's not
you're just basic mcdonald's employee
who gets to demand these things of you
your basic middle manager who then drunk
on power is going to freak out at you
and start calling you names if the new
york city police department is asked to
do this will they do it you think they
will do it oh absolutely i was talking
to
some guys at the nypd that i met at um
some black trans rights lives matter
protests over the summer that were
actually rather amusing and uh
i was talking to a guy who said that the
nypd in fact declined to enforce social
distancing mandates
what happened was
it was early on it was like may 2020
and they were being asked to enforce
social distancing they were going out
into the communities where there was the
most coveted most active coveted so what
were these communities these were mostly
minority communities so they're
wandering around like
fort greene or whatever you know like
crown heights
wandering around like um
bed stuy looking for black people and
latino people on their stoop having
barbecues right and then telling them to
go inside so the guys i was talking to
and the force they were like that was a
really super bad look that we were like
breaking up
you know here we are we're told to
be less enforcing
of things in these communities we had
done stop and frisk whatever else they
pulled back on that and now they're
supposed to tell them to all go inside
so they refused they declined to enforce
that they declined to enforce the mask
thing if you go around if you're on the
ny um
new york city subway system and you
happen to spot a police officer
which is
not super frequent these days but if you
haven't spot them they're not wearing
masks lots of other people are wing
masks the nypd declined to enforce this
stuff in fact do you i don't know if you
guys remember there was a bar in staten
island yeah that was like very vocally
opposed so it was the state police that
were enforcing that stuff because that's
who cuomo had control over well then the
state police are going to come in and do
it do you think that the state police
would end up with that this is the
normal thing they do they bring in
outside cops because you know if you're
a cop in new york
you're worried that
if the nypd steps on toes of the locals
then you're not going to be able to go
to restaurants you're not going to be
able to like get people throwing stuff
at you so
it happened in uh with with attila's gym
that's right new jersey the local cops
from that town showed up and said have a
nice day everybody and left right so
they brought in outside cops who came in
and said screw you with a smile on their
face and put the boot down you know yeah
i wonder how that would go down um
hopefully nobody ever has to find out
what a disaster is what a total
nightmare they did it with the bar they
shut it down there was a bar in staten
island and the guy was he wasn't even
selling anything he was like just i'll
give it away for free i guess and then
the state police came and
stood in front of the building
they i think they arrested the guy right
yeah they arrested him multiple times
and there was literally a bar like a
block and a half away that was allowed
to operate and he wasn't because they
did like zones they did these stupid
zones
yeah there was also as though these
zones are impossible my son tells me
about this you know we'll go into a
restaurant and then you don't have to
take it before and and he'd be like oh
well that's right once we sit down we
can take our masks off because chairs
are coveted blockers that's true he's
11. he's 11 and he sees through this
mess you know this is the craziest thing
i love there's a meme where it's like uh
they
someone pulls up to a drive-through and
they're being handed a there's a tray
holding like the wendy's bag and then
the person's like what's this and
they're like it's your food it's like
why is it on the tray and they're like
for covid it's like
why can't you just hand me the bag
because you're trying to reduce contact
it's like you mean to tell me that you
literally handled the meat handled the
bread handled the lettuce you put it all
in the wrapper put it all in the bag
you've touched it all already and now
you've put on a tray that you won't
touch that so you're not so you're not
touching the bag the one last time if
anything you've increased the amount of
contact you made by holding the tray
just give me the food early on at the
post-millennial we were running a lot of
stories like that because they were just
so hysterical and there was one with
like a guy at tim hortons pushing out a
coffee on a hockey stick
that's really funny oh man you know it's
not helping that's why i'm saying we are
chickens in a chicken coop
that's i guess yeah some of the chickens
are like hey something's not right the
when you guys earlier talk about state
police coming in it made me think of the
shea's rebellion uh are you familiar
with this rebellion right after the they
fed the uh the confederate basically
after the united states did the uh what
is that 13 colonies yeah what was it
called the
13th century yeah it was before they did
the declaration of independence they had
like an original document that they were
using articles
and the states had too much control and
their their own police wouldn't enforce
like the farmer's rebellion wanted the
courts shut down the police were like no
let them we these are our friends we're
not going to stop them so they had to
call in the the state police
and then they were like this is too
dangerous to give so much power locally
we need to federalize
and in a way they're right because they
were able to organize taxes and military
but
you know the danger of that is now you
can send in the feds thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to see the full show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments and
super chat and we actually will read
your comments on the show don't forget
to like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time